A new super-stretchy polymer material from
Stanford University can heal itself at room
temperature and could lead to self-healing
electronic circuits as well as electronic
skin for prosthetics and robots.
And EPFL scientists have proposed a new model
for understanding how the brain processes
information.
Suggesting that stimulus is processed unconsciously
and then perceived consciously in 400 millisecond
intervals called Time Slices.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Teslaphoresis causes nanowire to remotely
assemble using a force field.
A Tesla coil designed by researchers from
Rice University oscillates positive and negative
charges in each carbon nanotube which causes
them to chain together.
They created a functioning circuit connecting
two LEDs that is powered by the tesla coil
field.
It’s the first time electric fields have
been observed moving matter on a large scale
and they believe this could lead to breakthroughs
in regenerative medicine, and artificial systems
that can self-assemble without physical contact.
SkinHaptics uses ultrasound to provide tactile
feedback for interfaces on your hand.
The array emits ultrasound through the back
of the hand to create sensation in a focused
point of the palm.
The prototype is admittedly large but they’re
already working on a significantly smaller
version - with the plan one day to implement
this alongside flexible screen technology
to turn your hand into an interactive electronic
device.
Which could pair quite nicely with ultraflexible
organic photonic skin.
The smart e-skin system, developed at the
University of Tokyo, allows for a two-color
logo display as well as a red seven-segment
digital display.
Along with being a display that’s one order
magnitude thinner than the epidermal layer
of skin, the plan is for this to also monitor
health by measuring oxygen levels in the blood.
Challenges to further development include
protecting the e-skin from being destroyed
and finding a power source like flexible batteries
or the energy from harvesting your body heat.
A neural bypass is allowing a man to retrain
his paralyzed hand.
In 2014, researchers at The Ohio State University
Wexner Medical Center implanted a chip in
Ian Burkhart’s brain - an algorithm then
translates his thoughts into impulses for
a sleeve on his arm, bypassing his spinal
cord.
In less than two years of working with and
training the system he’s gone from picking
up a spoon to playing Guitar Hero and swiping
credit cards.
And they’re confident this system could
help stroke victims as well as differently
abled people in the future.
We may be one step closer to functional smart-clothes.
Researchers at Ohio State University were
able to embroider circuits into fabric with
0.1mm precision, a perfect size to incorporate
sensors and memory devices into clothes.
Further development could see smart phone
antennas in shirts, performance-monitoring
sports equipment, and even bandages that can
tell your doctor how tissue is healing.
The best part is the embroidered wires feel
the same as typical thread.
Mind Blow #43 back in June 2012, featured
Joggobot - a drone designed to accompany joggers
by using tracking markers on a special t-shirt.
Well Skydio is a new drone that autonomously
follows bikers and joggers while avoiding
obstacles without requiring special clothing.
It uses a multi-camera array and onboard computing
to map and plan its navigation rather than
simply reacting to things it might crash into.
While this is just a prototype - their goal
is to bring it to consumers and in their words
create a “magical experience.”
Finally, check out this new augmented reality
demo from Magic Leap - this video is shot
through the mixed reality technology.
I’m gonna leave you with an animation from
NASA on the future of space exploration.
And as always - thanks for watching.
Fingertip shopping will be one of the many
homemaker's conveniences.
This video console will be channeled into
the store of her choice.
There, a camera will scan a display of wares
she which will select by push button.
What the wife selects on her console, will
be paid for by the husband at his counterpart
console.
All bills and transactions will be carried
out electronically.
Also at his disposal, is an electronic correspondence
machine or home post office.
Which allows for instant written communication
between individuals anywhere in the world.